somewhere some document says I am
entitled to the pursuit of happiness I
can't think of many things that make
most people happier than sex
prostitution is illegal in California
just like everywhere else in the United
States besides a few rural Nevada
counties but a new lawsuit is raising
legal challenges to California's ban on
what some call the world's oldest
profession
our hope in the lawsuit is to have the
prostitution law or the
anti-prostitution law ruled
unconstitutional and invalidated in the
state of California
Maxine Dugan is a former sex worker and
head of California's erotic service
provider legal educational and research
project s pleure the non-profit behind
the lawsuit naming the state attorney
general and several police chiefs as
defendant the most problems I have seen
as a result of being forced into the
underground economy is we don't have
access to equal protection under the law
a very very broad anti-prostitution
statute violates and constitutional
right to privacy
Gerald Mosley is the former supervising
Deputy Attorney General under Kamala
Harris plaintiff in s Blair's lawsuit
he's now an outspoken advocate for the
legalization of sex work the united
Supreme Court decision
in the case of Lawrence vs Texas it was
decided in 2003 that case that decision
is going to be the most important tool
for the plaintiffs to use in this erotic
service versus Gascon in that case two
gay men who were convicted under a
statute that forbade sodomy between
members of the same sex the Supreme
Court looked at that statute and said
that is unconstitutional no legislature
can't look at majoritarian moral values
what the majority morally disapproves of
and make that the basis
for banning the conduct or throwing
people in jail s blurs lawsuit boils
down to three main constitutional issues
we have found in the Constitution that
an American has a privacy right and
sexual conduct is the most private of
conduct this man goes by the name
Bacchus and like one plaintiff at the
center of s blurrs case he suffers from
a medical condition that makes having a
normal sexual relationship difficult
when my mother was pregnant with me
after a miscarriage
for her first attempt her doctors
recommended diethylstilbestrol hormone
the FDA withdrew use of CES in 1971
after scientists discovered links to
birth defects including genital
abnormalities a condition called the
hypospadias which is when the urethra
doesn't reach the end of the penis in
old times they used to kill babies with
that condition because it wasn't curable
they put me in a crib with a indwelling
catheter called the balloon catheter and
I climbed out of the crib fell to the
floor and yanked the balloon catheter
out of my freshly operated on penis
which caused a dramatic amount of damage
the net result is I have an unusually
small and unusually numb dick called
microphallus when I did date I would you
know joke about it got shot off in the
Vietnam War or something so I didn't
have to suffer her disappointment for my
own after years of frustration and
disappointment bakas eventually sought
the counsel of ascend
therapists who prescribed him a sex
surrogate she basically told me you've
got some physical nerve damage
I can't work around it's not mental it's
not magic there's no backdoor literally
into getting you off it's something you
got to live with that led me to
prostitution basically for lots and lots
of people I think there's this need
which is very itself kind of stigmatized
and under acknowledged in society of how
important sexual and romantic
companionship is to people and in life
Starchild is a libertarian activist and
sex worker based in San Francisco I've
had clients who are in their 80s
possibly even older I've had clients are
over 300 pounds of clients who are
disabled client's blind we can't even
control our own most intimate functions
and be able to provide those then what
other freedoms do we meaningfully have
before you decide to make it illegal you
have to look at the associations and
rights and you also have to look at the
fact that people make a living that is a
livelihood an athlete who sells a very
personal and very bodily oriented
service for the entertainment of others
who pay that athlete for that service
that's the athletes labor that is being
sold which is quite proper the athlete
is not selling himself people like us
are willing to offer this at a price
some people have negative feelings about
that like how can you you know exploit
people who are lonely and whatever it's
like well at least we're willing to
provide it to them at some price most of
you are not willing to provide that in
any price and then where are these
people going to be
people have a right to their intimate
personal associations researchers have
found that very often as strange as it
may sound sex is just the pretext for
visiting a call-girl
there are emotional and relational needs
that are being satisfied by many of
these relationships having a woman in my
life who I can call up on the phone and
say I'd like to get together tonight we
can come to you can come to my place we
can go get a motel take a trip for a
couple days it it makes me feel like a
member of humanity the Attorney
General's Office declined our request
for an interview but in their motion to
dismiss the case they say the law
prohibiting prostitution is rationally
related to California's interest in
deterring human trafficking and coercion
violence against prostitutes the spread
of AIDS and venereal diseases and crimes
incidental to prostitution as well as
California's interest in deterring
commodification of sex this is a
scientific matter it's not an emotional
or a political matter prostitution is
not a significant vector in the spread
of STDs or HIV the former Surgeon
General Joslin elders Surgeon General
United States has come out for
decriminalizing prostitution and her
concern is health because if you
decriminalize prostitution
it will help restrain HIV when we are
debating violence we need to make sure
what we are talking about and if we are
talking about women who are suffering
actual physical violence then the
response is we need to protect them and
not criminalize them there was a 2012
Chicago study that found that police
were actually liable for more violence
including sexual violence than pimps
women from our standpoint I think we try
to avoid the police as much as possible
there is a deliberate attempt to
conflate prostitution and trafficking it
used to be you know generation a couple
generations ago all about you know
people who do this are immoral they
started finding people actually you know
have a lot of sympathy with sex workers
and so now the new thing is that that
we're being exploited although people
like me are basically invisible in this
narrative right now the state arrests
people that they think are victims of
human trafficking under the prostitution
law so it's essentially in our state we
have traffic victims arrested money is
involved in in most of these rights that
we cherish and value so to say that
suddenly sex isn't protected anymore as
a right just because there's money
involved is really flying in the face of
of all our other rapes when we talk
about commodification you know we're
signaling that we don't approve of
what's going on we're not signaling why
we don't approve we're not giving
reasons for disapproving of prostitution
we're just signaling that we have a very
very deep emotional opposition to it I
think the judicial system is where we're
going to find our relief and I really
think that the American public is ready
they're ready to throw off all of these
draconian laws and move forward as a
society I believe that the laws are old
and they're based on old laws and
they're based on old morals I believe
the government is reaching too far into
my personal life right now
[Music]